بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله
والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك له
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله
وصحبه ومن والاه واتبع هداه الى يوم الدين
اما بعد
انتهينا الى بدايه
سيره النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم الموجزه
التي ساقها لنا الحافظ ابن القيم رحمه
الله تعالى
وذكرنا ايامه
في مكه
وبدايات الدعوه الى الله سبحانه وتعالى
ومضى غالبا وقته
عليه الصلاه والسلام في مكه وحيدا
وكان صلى الله عليه وسلم يهاجم
من قبل اعدائه
وكان من الاب من الامر ما ذكرناه
وقد وصلنا
الى الهجره
هجره النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم من مكه الى
مدينه الى المدينه
هذه الهجره
هي
كما قال ابن القيم رحمه الله
هي التي فرق الله بها بين اوليائه واعدائه
وجعلها مبدا لاعزاز دينه ونصره رسوله صلى
الله عليه وسلم
هجره
هذا حدث جلل في تاريخ الاسلام بل في تاريخ
الامه والانسانيه
فان النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم هاجرا من
مكه الى المدينه
خرج من بيني اعدائه الى اوليائه من الاوس
والخزرج
وابتدا ظهور الاسلام
بالهجره النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
وقد كتب الله سبحانه وتعالى ان تكون دولته
في المدينه
عند الاوس والخزرج
وقد عرض
كثيرون عليه صلى الله عليه وسلم ان يهاجر
اليهم
اهل دوس دوس هي بلد ابي هريره رضي الله
عنه بعض اهل اليمن وهكذا عرضوا عليه لكن
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم لم يهاجر اليهم
لانه لم يجد
المنعه التي يحتاج اليها عندهم
فكتب الله سبحانه وتعالى هذا الشرف لاهل
المدينه
لاهل يثرب
وبعد ان هاجر اليها
صار اسمها الى مدينه رسول الله
صلى الله عليه وسلم
وبدون اضافه المدينه المدينه
وكذلك قيل لها المدينه المنوره
بانها كما قال انس رضي الله عنه
لما
هاجر النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم الى
المدينه اضاءت واضاءه كل شيء
وهذه الاضاءه المذكوره هي اضاءه
روحانيه
وهي اضاءه اضاءه وجود العدل والاحسان
والامان
وان كانوا فيه
مكابده اشياء صعبه وواعره جدا
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم هاجر اليها
فاستنارت المدينه فقيل لها المدينه
المنوره
وقال انس لما توفي رسول الله صلى الله
عليه وسلم
فان هذا النور لم يعد كائنا كما
كانت في هذه هذا النور لم يعد كما كان في
عهد رسول الله وفي حياته عليه الصلاه
والسلام فقيل لها المدينه المنوره منوره
بسنته عليه الصلاه والسلام والله عز وجل
جعل هذه المدينه حرما
هي حرم
وهي ثاني اعظم
مساجد في الارض واذا لاحظنا هذه المساجد
الثلاثه المسجد
الحرام
ومسجد النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم المسجد
النبوي
ومسجد الاقصى وجدنا ان هذه
المساجد كلها
نتيقن نحن نعلم يقينا ان هذه المساجد
بناها نبي
هذه المساجد بناها الانبياء ابراهيم عليه
السلام بل
وقد يكون الراجح
وهو خلاف بين اهل التفسير ان المسجد
الحرام بناه ادم عليه السلام هو اول مسجد
الله عز وجل يقول
ان اول بيت وضع للناس الى الذي ببكه
مباركا وهدى للعالمين فيه ايات بينات
مقاموا ابراهيم فهذا كان اول مسجد
بناه نبي ووضع للناس واذن الله سبحانه
وتعالى فيه بذكره وعبادته
والمسجد الحرام
لذلك فان ابراهيم عليه السلام
اراه الله سبحانه وتعالى مكان البيت
اراه مكان البيت
وهو رفع جدران هذا البيت واذ يرفع ابراهيم
القواعد من البيت اذا القواعد موجوده
فالله عز وجل
اعلمه بمكان
الكعبه
فاعاد ابراهيم عليه السلام بناء الكعبه
هذا قول وقول اخر ان ابراهيم عليه السلام
هو الذي بنى الكعبه المشرفه اول مره وهذا
وهما قولاني مشهوران معروفان بين العلماء
المسجد النبوي بناه رسول الله محمد صلى
الله عليه وسلم خاتم الانبياء والرسل
والمسجد الاقصى بناه يعقوب عليه السلام
واعاد بنائه وترميمه سليمان
عليه وعلى جميع الانبياء افضل الصلوات
والتسليمات على كل حال
هذه المساجد
مميزه من بين جميع مساجد الارض بانها
بناها انبياء
مسجد الحرام مسجد نبوي والمسجد الاقصى
الله عز وجل جعل المدينه حرما
حرم المدينه ودعا النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم للمدينه
فقال بارك لنا اللهم بارك لنا في مدها
وكيلها
كان فيها بركه وفيها
وفيها لما وصل النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
فيها كان
كان فيه في المدينه حمى معروفه كل واحد
يجي يهاجر من
الى المدينه يستوخمها يعني يمرض
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم دعا
فالله عز وجل ابعد هذه الحمى من المدينه
ومن ميزات المسجد النبوي ان الدجال لا
يدخله
قد جاء عن النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم ان
الدجال
يدخل كل
بلده على وجه الارض الا مكه والمدينه الا
مكه والمدينه
ياتي عليهما فيجد الملائكه
سالين سيوفهم
على
طرق وابواب المدينه وابواب المسجد الحرام
فلا يستطيع دخولهما
وهذا يدلنا على ان الدجال
انسان يعني بعض الناس يفسر الدجال يقول
المسيح الدجال مثلا
الكمبيوتر او المسيح الدجال مثلا يعني
القنوات الفضائيه المفسده او ما شابه ذلك
هذه قد تكون من من اثري
فتنه الدجال لكن الدجال نفسه هو شاب
مملوء شبابا
ووصفه لنا رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
ولا يستطيع دخول مكه ولا دخول المدينه هذه
الاشياء دخلت
فعلى كل حال
المقصود ان هذه الهجره الى هذه البلاد
العظيمه التي بارك الله سبحانه وتعالى
فيها
فان هذه الهجره كانت هي بدايه الفصل بين
اولياء الله واولياء الشيطان لذلك كان
التاريخ كان التاريخ الشرعي الاسلامي
بدءا من الهجره
بعدا من الهجره
يسال سائل يقول التاريخ
تاريخ الهجري اول شهر فيه
اول شهر شو هو شهر ايش
شهر محرم والهجره كانت متى
شهر
ربيع الاول
كيف التاريخ بدا بالهجره نقول
الصحابه رضي الله عنهم لم ينظروا الى
بدايه تحركه من مكه الى المدينه هذا كان
في شهر ربيع لكن
بدايه العزم على المدينه
عقد العزم والنيه على الهجره من مكه الى
المدينه
وتجهيز ذلك وبدايات الهجره من قبل الصحابه
الذين سبقوه اليها كان هذا في شهر شهر
الله محرم فكان اول شهر في التاريخ
السنوي من اشهر
من اشهر
التاريخ الاسلامي هو محرم محرم اول شهر
وصحيح النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم هاجره في
ربيع الاول لكن هذا هذه الهجره
كانت مسبقه بتخطيط
عزيمه وعزم
وهكذا والصحابه ابتدئوا الهجره من مكه الى
المدينه في شهر محرم
وهذا التاريخ
يعني الصحابه رضي الله عنهم لما ارخوا
وابتداوا التاريخ الشرعي الاسلامي
في عهد عمر رضي الله عنه الفاروق
فانهم عدلوا عن التاريخ
بمولد النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم وعادلوا
عن التاريخ
بليله القدر او ليله
ابتداء الوحي الى رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم وهذه كانت
مقترحات
طرح الصحابه رضي الله عنهم اجتمعوا في عهد
عمر رضي الله عنه وكان ثم عقود
وحقوق بين الناس
فقالوا كيف
نؤرخ حتى
تتم هذه العقود واحد بيقول في شهر كذا طيب
الشهر الماضي الشهر الاتي او الذي بعده او
الذي قبله
فاحتاجوا الى تاريخ يقولوا سنه كذا قبل
هيك كانت العرب تؤرخ من وقعت
وقعت الفيل
وهكذا يعني صار اشي عظيم مثلا مرض انتشر
في زمن معين او كانت فيه حرب في سنه معينه
يقول سنه كذا
وينسبون السنه الى هذه
الواقعه وكذلك كان اعظم هذه الوقائع يوم
الفيل يوم الفيل
فكانوا يقولون مولود في السنه كذا خمس
سنوات بعد
حادثه الفيل او عشر سنوات بعد حادثه الفيل
وهكذا يؤرخون
لكن هذا ليس دقيقا
احتاج الى
تحتاج الى تاريخ
يستطيعون بذلك تنظيم الحقوق والعقود
اقترح بعض الصحابه ان يكون ذلك التاريخ
مبدوءا من
هجره من مولد النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
وقال بعضهم من ليله الاسراء والمعراج قال
بعضهم
ليله ابتداء الوحي قال بعضهم بيوم ابتداء
دعوته لكن هذه
عدل عنها لماذا لانها مختلف فيها مختلف
فيها
اي يوم تماما واي زمن
بالضبط كان
مولد النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم او هذه
الاشياء
فقالوا نبتدا
التاريخ الاسلامي وقت ان فرق الله سبحانه
وتعالى وسنه ان فرق الله سبحانه وتعالى
بين اوليائه واوليائه الشيطان وبين اعدائه
فوقع الاختيار على الهجره فنحن الان
نؤرخ
بتاريخ المعروف بالتاريخ الهجري يعني هذه
اعظم
اعظم حدث كان او حادثه
في التاريخ الاسلامي الذي كان حقيقا
بان يجعل ابتداء للتاريخ
فيقول ابن القيم رحمه الله
فصل في مبدا الهجره التي فرق الله بها بين
اوليائه واعدائه
وجعلها مبدا لاعزاز دينه ونصره رسوله صلى
الله عليه وسلم
يقول قال الزهري حدثني محمد بن صالح عن
عاصم بن عمر بن قتاده ويزيد بن رومان
وغيرهما قالوا اقام رسول الله صلى الله
عليه وسلم بمكه ثلاث سنين من اول نبوته
يوافي الموسم كل عام
يتبع الحاج او في منازلهم يعني يذهب الى
منازل الحجاج ويدعوهم الى الاسلام
ويعرض نفسه عليهم
لياخذوه وفي المواسم بعكاظ عكاظ هذا سوق
معروف وذي المجاز ايضا سوق معروف من اسواق
مكه
يدعوهم الى ان يمنعوه حتى يبلغ رسالات ربه
ولهم الجنه فلا يجد احدا ينصره ولا يجيبه
حتى انه ليسال عن القبائل ومنازلها قبيله
قبيله فيقول يا ايها الناس قولوا لا اله
الا الله تفلحوا وتملك بها العرب وتدين
لكم بها العجم فاذا
كنتم ملوكا في الجنه
وابو لهب وراءه يقول لا تطيعوه فانه صابئ
كذاب سابق
في لغه
الناس في ذاك الوقت هو الذي
ان حل عن دين ابائه الذي رفض دين ابائه
وحول تحول من دين اجداده الى دين اخر يقال
هذا صابئ
فقال وكانت هذه بمنزله المسبه يعني كانه
يسب اجداده يسب ابائه لانهم كانوا يعظمون
الاباء
تعظيما فوق المعقول
حتى انهم يعني يقولون اذا انا اختلفت في
ديني مع ابائي اذا انا انصرفت عن دين
ابائي واجدادي فكانه
يسبهم يقول هم على خطا وانا على صواب هكذا
يظنون ولذلك النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم كان
من صميم دعوته لما سئل
ابو سفيان رضي الله عنه قبل ان يسلم ساله
هرقل كما في الصحيحين ماذا يدعوكم اليه
فقال
يقول
اعبدوا الله ولا تشركوا به شيئا
واتركوا ما يقول اباؤكم هذه دعوته كانت
صلى الله عليه وسلم
فكانوا
يلقبونه بالصابئ
يعني الذي انصرف عنه دين ابائه فهم يقولون
هذا صابئ يعني هذا بسب اباءه بسب اجداده
فكانوا يرون هذه يعني
يعني مسبه للاجداد
فاذا قالوا لاحد ما صابئ صابئا فهذا معناه
انهم
يسبونه فكان ابو لهب وراءه في هذه الاسواق
نفرغ نفسه بس لهذا الرسول صلى الله عليه
وسلم يدعو الى الله وهو
وهو
جعل نفسه ووقته
وقفا للشيطان لان يتبعه في هذه الاسواق
ويقول لا تطيعوه فانه صابئ كذاب
ويردون على رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
اقبح الرد ويؤذونه
ويقولون عشيرتك اعلم بك حيث لم يتبعوك
من تبعك عشيرتكم نابدينك هكذا يقولون وهو
يدعوهم الى الله فهم لا يستمعون الى
الرساله الرساله لا ترفض
يعني احنا اذا قلنا رساله النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم اعبدوا الله الذي تؤمنون به هو
الذي رزقكم واعطاكم واحياكم ويميتكم وكل
الخير بيده وهكذا يخرون بذلك نحن نقول اذا
هو الوحيد مستحق لهذه العباده اصرف جميع
العباده الى الله سبحانه وتعالى ولا يستحق
احد ولا شيء سواه الى
شيء من العباده
فياتي في المقابل ويقولون لا نعبد الاصنام
ونعبد الاولياء ونعبد كذا وكذا
هذه ليست اصلا حجه يعني هذا لا يرد عقلا
لا يمكن لاحد سليم العقل
الا المكابر ان يرد هذه الدعوه ما يمكن
لكن القصه قصه
ينظرون الى
من الذي جاء بالرساله
ليش ما هو غني ليش ما هو عنده بساتين
وعنده لماذا
يرحمك الله
وينظرون الى عشيرته ماذا قالوا عنه
ينظرون الى الكبراء
والاسياد ماذا قالوا اذا نرفض اتباعا لهم
ليس
عقلا لذلك الله عز وجل
ذكر وامر النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم ان
يقول
انما اامركم بواحده قوموا لله مثنى وفرادى
ثم تتفكروا
فكر الواحد لحاله او يفكر الواحد مع واحد
ثاني معه ويتناقشوا المساله نقاش صحيح لا
يمكن التوصل الى الى نتيجه غير هذه
النتيجه
فهم يرفضون هذه الدعوه
ويقولون عشيرتك اعلم بك حيث لم يتبعوك وهو
يدعوهم الى الله
ويقول اللهم لو شئت لم يكونوا هكذا
فهو يتسلى
ويسلي نفسه بان هذا من مراد الله اراد
الله ذلك لحكمه الله اعلم بها فهو متوكل
على الله سبحانه وتعالى قال وكان
من سمي لنا من القبائل الذين عرض نفسه
عليهم ثم ذكر عده من القبائل كلهم
رفضوا ان
حرموا من هذا الشرف العظيم
فلم يستجب منهم احد وكان مما صنع الله
لرسوله صلى الله عليه وسلم ان الاوس
والخزرج كانوا يسمعون من حلفائهم يهود
المدينه ان نبيا سيخرج في هذا الزمان
فنتبعه
ونقتلكم معه قتل عاد وارم وكانت الانصار
يحجون كما كانت العرب تحج دون اليهود فلما
راوا رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم يدعو
الناس الى الله
وتاملوا احواله يعني اوصافه الذي
سمعوها الاوصاف والتي سمعوها من اليهود من
اهل الكتاب وكانوا يعظمون اهل الكتاب
المشركون عباد الاصنام
يعظمون اهل الكتاب لماذا لانهم كانوا
يؤمنون بان
بانهم اهل العلم من الله سبحانه وتعالى
فهم يعظمون اهل الكتاب لذلك اذا وقعوا في
ذنب ولمت بهم مصيبه عامه يفزعون الى اهل
الكتاب يستفتونهم ولذلك كان من صنيع
صناديد قريش انهم لما دعاهم النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم الى الاسلام
واعلن
نبوته ورسالته ارسلوا الوفود الى يهود
المدينه
ليستفتوهم عندنا واحد وصفه هيك هيك هيك
هل تجدون في كتابكم
شيئا من ذلك
فكانوا ماذا
يكتمون الكتاب ويكتمون اوصافه قال الله
تعالى
الذين اتيناهم الكتاب يعرفونه كما يعرفونه
ابنائهم
وانك فريقا منهم ليكتمون الحق وهم يعلمون
وازداد هذا النكران
لما هاجر النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم الى
المدينه هنا ان غابوا وماتوا غيظا
وممكن واحد يسال سؤال
يقول مثلا
شو كان اليهود يسووا في المدينه اصلا شو
اللي وصلهم للمدينه يعني
اهل الكتاب واسحاق عليه السلام كان في حول
بيت المقدس وكل اجدادهم هناك ايش اللي
وصلهم ليثرب
والجواب
انهم
سمعوا
او علموا من كتابهم وصف يثرب
يثرب كان كانت هذه المدينه معروفه بالنخل
النخيل
وعلموا انه سيخرج في هذا المكان سيبرز في
هذا المكان هذا النبي الامي
فظنوا
انهم اذا كانوا في المدينه
واكثر فيها من نسلهم ان هذا النبي يكون من
نسلهم ولا يكون من سلاله اسماعيل
ولذلك حرفوا اشياء كثيره قالوا الذبيح مين
الذبيح اسماعيل عليه السلام قالوا لا
اسحاق طب كيف يا جماعه ما هو اصلا موجود
في كتابكم ان هذه كانت قبل اصلا اسحاق
عليه السلام وقبل مولده قالوا لا اسحاق
ولبسوا لذلك العلماء يذكرون ان
القول بان الذبيح اسحاق عليه السلام نقله
بعض المفسرين
ذكروا ان هذا من دسائس
ومن
كذبات بني اسرائيل وتغييرهم للكتاب وتبديل
الكلام
فهم حقدوا على هذا الذي سيخرج من من يكون
من نسل اسماعيل عليه السلام
ويكون النبي الاعظم للانبياء وللناس
وللامم
فقالوا اذا رحلنا الى المدينه وكثرنا فيها
النسل وتوسعت العائلات ممكن يطلع من عنا
يعني بدهم يعني بالعربي بدهم يصيركوها
يعني نبوه
طبعا هذا شيء
يدلنا على على
انغراقهم في الماده
يظنون ان الماده هذه
تغير من قدر الله والنبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم يقول لا يغني حذر من قدر اذا قدر
الله شيء مهما اخذت من حذر مستحيل
ولذلك وصفهم الله عز وجل يهود المدينه
وصفاهم بماذا قال وظنوا انهم مانعتهم
حصونهم
من الله
من الله ظنوا ان حصونهم تمنعهم من رب
العالمين فالله عز وجل جعلهم يخربونها
بايديهم
مش بايدي بايديهم وايدي المؤمنين
سبحانه وتعالى فهم جماعه
يعني غرقانين في الماده والماديه حتى انهم
جعلوا الماده وكانها شريك مع الله والعياذ
بالله
فهم كانوا في المدينه لهذا السبب
وهم كانوا
تقع بينهم وبين المشركين في المدينه
اصل العرب هناك الاوس والخزرج كانوا عباد
اصنام كسائر العرب في ذاك الزمن
وكانوا يدعون انتسابا الى ابراهيم عليه
السلام يقولون احنا على دين ابراهيم
وطبعا كانت فيهم بقايا من دين ابراهيم
والا فهم ابراهيم عليه السلام منهم بريء
فكانت تكون مشاحنات بينهم وبين
العرب في المدينه
فكانوا يقولون
لهم
سياتي
ويبرز فينا نبي نؤمن به ونقتلكم معه قتل
عاد وارم
كان وصف الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم منتشر
بين بين جميع اهل المدينه
فلما
ظهر النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم في مكه وكان
الاوس والخزرج يذهبون الى الحج
وجدوه وسمعوا بعض ما يدعو اليه ونظروا الى
بعض احواله واوصافه
فاستيقنوا ان هذا هو النبي الذي
يذكرونه
ويصفونه لنا
والعجيب
ان هؤلاء العرب المشركين الذين كانوا
يعبدون الاصنام سمعوا من هذا سمعوا بهذا
النبي من اليهود هم امنوا به واليهود
كافروا به
وكان ماذا
كان هؤلاء اسلموا وامنوا به وقتلوا يهود
المدينه قتل عاد واراد وسبحان الله
على كل حال
المقصود ان اليهود في المدينه كانوا
متواجدين هناك لهذا السبب يقول
ابن القيم رحمه الله وكان مما صنع الله
لرسوله ان الاوس والخزرج كانوا يسمعون من
حلفائهم يهود المدينه ان نبيا سيخرج في
هذا الزمان فنتبعه ونقتلكم معه قتل عاد
وارم
وكانت الانصار يحجون كما كانت العرب تحج
دون اليهود فلما راوا رسول الله صلى الله
عليه وسلم يدعو الناس الى الله وتاملوا
احواله قال بعضهم لبعض تعلمون والله يا
قوم ان هذا الذي
توعدكم به اليهود فلا يسبقنكم اليه
فامنوا
وكان السويد بن الصامت سويد ابن الصامت من
الاوس قد قدم مكه فدعاه رسول الله صلى
الله عليه وسلم
فلم يبعد ثم قدمها انس ابن رافع فيه فتيه
من بني عبد الاشهل يطلبون
الحلف فدعاهم الى الاسلام فقال اياس ابن
معاذ وكان شابا يا قوم هذا والله خير مما
جئنا له
اجينا لغرض وهذا خير مما جئنا له فضربه
انس وانتهره فسكت فانصرفوا الى المدينه
هذه كانت اول
مصادفه بين النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم ومن
جعلهم الله سبحانه وتعالى في مستقبل امرهم
هم انصاره كان لهم هذا الشرف قيل لهم
الانصار لانهم نصروه واواه رضي الله عنهم
ونصروا اتباعه يقول الله سبحانه وتعالى في
سوره البقره
ولما جاءهم كتاب من عند الله
مصدق لما معهم وكانوا من قبل يستفتحون على
الذين كفروا
فلما جاءهم ما عرفوا كفروا به فلعنه الله
على الكافرين بئس ما اشتروا به انفسهم ان
يكفروا بما انزل الله باغيا ان ينزل الله
من فضله على من يشاء من عباده
فباؤوا بغضب على غضب
هذه
الايات وهذه الكلمات في وصف هذا في وصف
اليهود الذين كانوا
يهددون اعدائهم بهذا النبي الذي سيخرج
ونقتلكم هم لم يريدوا ان يكونوا النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم لكونه
سبيلا للزلفه الى الله سبحانه وتعالى
ارادوا بس ان يظهروا على اعدائهم ويقهروهم
به فالله عز وجل كتب الايمان لاعدائهم
لان الله سبحانه وتعالى يقول
تلك الدار الاخره نجعلها للذين لا يريدون
علوا في الارض ولا فسادا
والعاقبه للمتقين
الذي يريد الاستعلاء في الارض هذا لا يوفق
على كل حال نكتفي باذن الله تعالى
بهذا القدر والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على
نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين
والحمد لله رب العالمين